hello everyone and welcome to the other
game that decided a spot in the
candidates tournament also from the
final round of the F Grand Swiss it is a
viit Gujarati versus Alexander p and
going into this round um viit if he wins
he of course gets a spot in the
candidates tournament if it's a draw
then most likely he gets a draw a spot
in the candidates tournament and if
Alexander P wins then Alexander gets a
spot in the FED candidates tournament
2024 so let's check it out and then we
are going to discuss who is in and who
will potentially get in over the course
of the year so videt had the white
pieces and he opened with D4 we have
Pawn to D5 C4 uh the Queen's gamut and
now D captures on C4 this is uh most
likely the best attempt at trying to win
with black um accepting the Queen's
Gambit Knight F3 Knight to F6 and pawn
to E3 now we have Pawn to E6 and Bishop
captures on C4 so the main line uh A6 we
have castles and now Pawn to C5 D
captures and C5 is the main move this is
what vid it plays we have Bishop
captures and a queen trade occurs so
captures captures and Bishop back to E2
uh the Knight will be able to come to E5
and you if you want you can shift the
bishop even to this long diagonal so
King to E7 uh Knight B to D2 and Bishop
to D7 again these are all moves that
have been played before Knight B3 Bishop
to B6 Bishop to D2 and Knight to C6 with
Bishop to C3 now claiming this long
diagonal for the dark Square Bishop Rook
H to G8 and now we have Rook F to D1 and
now there is a game as Deno coo played
it against veselin topalov in
2001 uh it was played in in Bosnia in
Saro and that game continued with Rook 8
to C8 by veling the game ended in a draw
but here we have Rook 8 to d8 and it is
now as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game so okay Rook a to C1
continuing development and now Pawn to
G5 PR wants more from this game than
just reshuffling pieces and going for
some sort of a calm draw Knight F to D4
and now Knight captures on D4 but before
we capturing first a nice Bishop to B4
check point being that if the Knight
comes to D5 you will not have to give up
the bishop you will be able to play
Bishop to C5 and counter Alexandra
strong dark Square Bishop on B6 so King
to E8 and now recapturing with Knight
captures on D4 so Pawn to G4 like I said
if if you go Knight D5 attack the bishop
then Bishop to C5 will be very strong
for white Pawn to G4 grabbing more space
on the king side and now Knight back to
B3 we have Rook to G5 uh not just
advancing the pawn for its own sake but
also to get the Rook into the game this
way we have Knight to C5 and now comes
Bishop to C6 point is that you don't
want to give up the bishop pair and also
you don't want to give up the B7 Pawn
but uh maybe perhaps the most um solid
way to play is just to give give up the
bishop pair and okay either everything
gets traded off or let's say Bishop
captures and then the Rook returns to
the C8 square like topalo played against
the Cal uh but here we have Bishop to C6
this is a pawn sacrifice but it does
Grant the Bishops this um these long
diagonals and okay vid it accepts he
plays Knight captures an A6 and grabs
the pawn uh if the pawn is if the Knight
is capture then of course The Rook
captures and C6 happens so Knight to D7
uh now also df5 Pawn d f Pawn can be
pushed and now Bishop to F1 uh we have
Rook to A8 going after the Knight but
now uh we have Bishop to D6 by viit and
this is a very very tricky move perhaps
even the best move of the game it's hard
to say um the idea is that while you
still can't capture the Knight as the
bishop is hanging you might play
something like let's say B3 to prepare
Pawn to A4 H but now this bishop to F3
move uh could be very annoying and if
you play let's say captures captures
this opens up a discovery will move the
king and now B captures on A6 happens uh
it's uh could be could be very dangerous
for white but after this bishop to D6
move uh it's much much different now if
you try the same idea let's say you go
for Bishop to F3 G captures G captures
with check King H1 and now B captures on
A6 uh Now The Rook already comes to C6
and uh very very hard to play this for
black it's it's very hard to even move
anything here uh so instead after Bishop
D6 Bishop to A4 was played putting
pressure on The Rook here and now we
have Bishop to F4 going after the Rook
on G5 also one of the uh reasons why the
bishop was very nicely placed on D6 we
have Rook to A5 now not going for The
Rook trade uh and Knight to C7 with
check forcing um Alexander to give up
the dark sare Bishop so Bishop captures
we have Bishop captures attacking the
rook and now Bishop captures on D1
Bishop captures on A5 Rook captures on
A5 and Rook captures on D1 so going into
a a full end game uh uh again you cannot
go after the pawn if you play uh Rook
captures on A2 then Bishop to B5 and you
now lose a piece and of course the game
so after Rook captures on D1 Knight to
E5 was played and now Pawn to A4 again
the pawn is defended with a tactic if
you capture on A4 then Bishop to B5
check um Forks the rook and the and the
King uh so after A4 Rook to C5 was
played and now we have Rook to D4 uh
defending and attacking on G4 we have
Rook to C1 uh and now Rook to B4 going
after the B7 Pawn we have Rook to B1 and
now is the moment you really have to
make a good decision uh so far vid
pretty much played everything perfectly
but you could very easily ruin it now uh
you don't capture the pawn that goes
without saying if you capture then goes
Knight to C4 and uh well you will have
huge problems here if the Knight lands
on D2 uh not not much uh you can do
after that so feel free to pause the
video and figure out how to continue the
game for vidit here while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this very fine maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to F4 uh giving your king uh
some breeding room with Tempo and now
you will be able to capture the pawn on
B7 and start advancing your past Aon
that is the way to Victory uh G captures
an F3 was played this is of course aasan
G captures Knight captures on F3 and
King to G2 just going after that Knight
Knight to D2 other attempts aren't much
better now you're attacking the bishop
on F1 Bishop to D3 attacks the rook and
Rook to E1 uh here vid it repeated once
uh he he wanted to see what Alexander
will play after King to F2 because he
can always repeat as well uh Rook H1
King G2 Rook to E1 and now only now Rook
captures on B7 so the pass Pawn has been
created and if you don't uh play
something extremely mean meaningful then
basically in four moves you resign so
Rook captures on E3 was played attacking
the bishop now Bishop to B5 check and
while you would of course go to the
queen side as that's where all the
action will be this will just blunder
the Knight on D2 so of course you have
to go King side King to f8 was played
and now Pawn to A5 with it's starts
pushing uh and as he's pushing he's
getting closer and closer to the
candidates tournament we have Rook to E5
he goes after the bishop but not really
as the bishop is defended A6 and now
Rook to G5 with check King F2 Knight to
E4 with check King E3 Knight to D6 now
attacking The Rook but of course vid
will not react a queen is much better
than a rook so Pawn to A7 uh and now
Rook to E5 check few more checks will be
given but that's all there is King F3
Rook to F5 with check King G2 uh sorry
King to G2 was played uh Rook to G5 with
check King to H1 and he was in this
position on move 47 uh that Alexandra
PKA resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here there's no
way to complicate no way to try anything
to force anything uh A8 Queen is
Unstoppable and that's pretty much all
there is you can take the Rook of course
uh but A8 Queen comes with check so even
that doesn't help you King G7 Queen
captures defends the bishop uh of course
a queen and Bishop for a rook uh not not
much point in continuing this so after
King to H1 he resigned uh he played an a
beautiful tournament he he played
attacking chess and got great results
with it and you know in the final round
he did have a chance with the black
pieces to qualify for the candidates but
it is vidit who will be joining Hikaru
through the FID Grand Swiss into the
2024 FID candidates tournament and uh uh
just if you guys are interested here are
vid's results throughout the rounds he
actually started a tournament tournament
with a loss which is quite incredible
not only does he qualify for the
candidates he also wins the F Grand
Swiss that's absolutely amazing and you
know to start with a loss and to win it
uh that means he definitely got a lot of
wins afterwards so uh all of his
opponents were grandm he defeated gup
coliro then a draw against y ner then
back-to-back wins against Hans Neiman
and jaak sarov then two draws to Hikaru
and aseno and finishing it off nicely
with win against the ban Daniel Dak and
Alexander PR now in the final round so
uh now we know six of the candidates of
the FED candidates tournament and um uh
two more spots will be rewarded one spot
will be rewarded uh via the uh so-called
the F Fay circuit and the one will be
rewarded uh via the highest rating as of
January 2024 so uh it's still hard to
say who will it be for example if we
check out the uh the live ratings you
can see that okay uh alira is 2762 and
uh above him are nepo Hikaru and Fabiano
who have already qualified ding is the
world champion so he cannot qualify and
Magnus does not want to play so he will
not qualify so ala should qualify via
VIA the highest rating if he manages to
remain the highest rated player you know
until January 2024 and he did lose 14
points now so he did get much much
closer to Anish uh so you know Anish and
Wesley and perhaps um kakin are all in
that realm of of maybe even catching up
to Ala and qualifying via the highest
rate maybe even un un qualifies it you
know it's not
uh impossible I mean that's like 12 12
rating points uh so ala has the highest
chance of qualifying uh via the highest
rating and uh here are some of the
standings from the uh fiday circuit so
fab is currently leading the Fay circuit
with 104 points but he's already
qualified and the second um in the Fay
circuit is none other than GES he has
7950 points uh and the next to him is
Wesley so with 78. 84 and then it uh
it's Anish giri with
7587 so through the through the Fay
circuit uh best chances have gukesh
Wesley and Anish giri and through the
highest rating as you've seen it's alza
but also it could be anyone else so it's
still very hard to say who will be the
last two candidates best chances for now
alira and and GES but also Anish giran
both of yeah it's it will be very hard
to say uh we'll just have to wait and
see uh so yeah uh that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it big congratulations
to Hikaru and vidit on on qualifying and
also to vidit on on actually winning the
FID Grand Swiss it's an incredible
achievement over 160 players here uh
strongest Grand Masters in the world uh
definitely deserving of a spot in the
candidates tournament uh so yeah uh
that's the game and a little bit of
extra info if uh I I'll probably make
another video on on the event probably
will cover some of uh vali's games as
she also qualified for the candidates
tournament I don't know if it's the
first time uh in history that we have a
brother and sister who have qualified
simultaneously for a candidates
tournament uh but I I'm pretty sure it
will be the first time that we have a
brother and sister uh who are
simultaneously Grand Masters whence sh
is awarded her grandmas title so you
know absolutely incredible on that front
as well uh but yeah hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Sams giant toris
farm Marvin Sparrow Gerhard hlan
perforce a love Marie and India for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day okay